[Music]
good afternoon good evening or perhaps
good morning um wherever you are i want
to welcome all of you to today's panel
your journey uh now i know five years
out so we're going to be
speaking to some gsb alums who graduated
in um
the class of 2016 and our five years
post graduation
today's event
i'm going to just give a brief
introduction to our global community
i'll talk a little bit about the alumni
population
and representation of the gsb around the
world i'm going to introduce our
panelists in fact i'm going to have them
introduce themselves um
and uh i have some q a for them just
test start off things to hear their
experience about their time at the gsp
and for them to share that with you
um but i also want this to be somewhat
interactive as interactive as we can be
on zoom so if there are specific
questions you have for the panelists um
either off the top of your head right
now or something that comes up as they
are sharing and speaking um feel free to
ask that question in the q a pod i'll be
monitoring those you have the chance to
upvote those so if someone asks
something you also want to hear the
answer to feel free to do that and i'll
try to monitor we'll get to as many of
those as we can and but we do have um
just about 50 more minutes together so
this time usually flies right by and
like i said we'll try to answer as much
as we can
so and with that uh the gsb alumni i
hope that the five folks or the four
panelists joining us today can attest to
the fact that um it's a strong network
um but numerically it's 30 000 plus uh
alumni globally
represented around the world there's
actually 60 volunteer-led chapters that
are regionally um based
um in addition to that there's also
diversity chapters and different
programs to support women um
i'm curious to hear from harald and
emily whether they're involved in either
of those but our women's circles is a
strong program in place to support women
after
and in addition to just the network that
i'm sharing about um right now there's
also support that continues beyond the
gsb we'll talk a little bit about the
role the cmc might have played in
helping our panelists um secure their
jobs or positions post gsb but there's
also support that continues um after
being a student too and so we can talk a
little bit about that
um
with that i want our panelists to go
ahead and introduce themselves i have a
little bit of information up about each
of them
um but i want them to to kind of go
through who they are and what they were
doing before the gsb and where they are
now and in addition to just introducing
yourself you guys if you don't mind
sharing um with the group today what was
perhaps your most impactful
experience this could be a course that
you took or um
of course you took or just you know an
experience you had whether it was
travels or something extracurricular or
personal whatever it may have been
during your time at the gsb uh we'll
just go across where the names are so
emily you are first
amazing hi everybody uh excited to be
chatting with you all also excited to
see all my fellow uh
alums on the call
uh so as the slide says uh i went to
yale undergrad
prior to the gsb i spent a lot of time
at bain bain and company consulting and
worked predominantly within their retail
space i also worked a little bit in the
nonprofit space
um
and then after the gsb
i went back to vayne for a little bit
but i also had fun
um times in startup land at apple
um and then have landed back now in like
the design and retail world so that's um
my current employer is f schumacher and
co so
you can see this awesome wallpaper
that's actually welcome
and
so many amazing uh memories and like
meaningful experiences
uh i will talk probably about
uh
just a trip to india actually that i
took um so
this was actually like coordinated and
organized similar to a gst and we sort
of copied a gst but it was with um one
of like the people that i became very
close to bharat in our class
um and he is
an amazing indian man who took us all
around india um but what was so special
about it is that it was this
really diverse group of people from all
over the world
um and bharat cared and loved his
country so much and getting to
experience it through his eyes
um
was like truly uh
like super super memorable um and i
still
uh remember all of the amazing meals all
of the moments with politicians all of
the like crowded street corners
um and uh i'm excited that all those
folks are still very close to me
awesome thank you so much for sharing
um hurrah would you like to go next
yeah it's so great to meet everyone from
all over the world uh and i know people
are staying up late or waking up early
for this so hi my name is
i um i'm originally from india so i grew
up in india did undergrad back in mumbai
um and then us being at the forefront of
innovation and tech brought me here so i
studied computer science at carnegie
mellon and then join apple um really
working on some of the first generation
products i was in software engineering
very much heads down if some of you have
iphone i don't know if i can claim yet
but if you could make a call that was
because of me at least a decade ago i
don't think that's true anymore
um gsb was fun
i did venture capital i tried impact and
everything and came back to realizing my
heart is still in technology and
building things so i continued to be
on my journey to be more product
management and product leadership so
currently i'm at amplitude overseeing
kind of a product team
for those of you not aware amplitude is
a product analytics company so we build
products
tools for product managers which is a
great place to be
um with respect to uh my favorite
experience i think i'm following emily's
lead here is like travel is a big part
of gsp you'll all realize that and so
some of the memories and fond memories
always come from that for me
one of my founders was when we went to a
ship
to russia and serbia so i did see
someone from there as well which is
awesome
um i think this was not an official trip
led but two of our classmates are from
russia and i think for me the biggest
thing is i would have never otherwise
gone to russia unless they led a trip
but we also went in march so when we
were in like the uh
like you know rural parts of fade we've
seen like frozen lakes we also did like
ice skating on a the fresh water lake
called lake baikal and this the whole
site and spending time with the
classmates was like the most memorable
we had visited the prouder practice like
the news communism so understanding a
lot from that perspective from the
locals perspective was very eye-opening
versus just hearing what you read in the
media
and then yeah classes wise there's
always a lot more we can talk as we
evolve the conversations
sounds good thank you
i'm john you're next
all right uh
hello everyone um
similar to i'm john uh similar to emily
i also uh also went to yale um i studied
physics and mechanical engineering uh
and then did a masters at penn in
robotics after that um so as you can
probably assume i have focused a lot on
technology and robotics
both
after undergrad and after gsb
and spent some time at
mathworks which is a company that makes
matlab um
playing around with some of their
toolboxes and building a robotics
product there
and then yeah gsb i switched my focus
from being an engineer into doing more
product oriented stuff
and since then i've
been at a couple of different companies
in various parts of the robotics
industry so as i robot most immediately
after graduation which
which is the roomba company working on
some of their
some of their models
and
subsequently i was a company called
berkshire gray which is a industrial
automation provider which
actually recently went and went public
through spec and most recently just very
recently i joined waymo which is uh
which is google's um
autonomous car project so to speak so
yeah gsb was obviously very influential
i think we would all agree
that there's a lot of different aspects
of our gsb experiences that we'd love to
highlight here
i think that for me
i agree i think travel is one of the
more impactful things um
and but i'm gonna i'm gonna
highlight
what's called a g mix a global
management immersion experience uh that
i did during um during my summer uh
where um went to buenos aires uh to
work for i think it's a little over a
month or so at a
company called wormhole which does
online it's an online education platform
similar to coursera or
or edx um
but for the latin american market and
they're a small company
they still are a fairly small company
but at the time they were just under 30
folks and two of us from gsb went there
and we
got some scope it was kind of it was my
first experience doing anything product
management related and it was amazing to
learn and learn it from uh from uh the
folks at the argentine company and we
were really brought under the wing of
their leadership team which was a very
it was a very rewarding and special
experience because not only did they
introduce us to their product and their
way of doing things and we're very open
to hearing hearing our perspectives and
we were able to contribute and learn a
lot but they also helped introduce us to
the culture and we got to do a handful
of
fun activities in the city and really
have quite a unique experience
awesome thank you for sharing uh jason
do you mind introducing yourself and and
sharing also
of course um hey everyone my name is
jason scott sorry i'm coming to you from
mobile so if my phone falls
it's my fault not yours
but i am currently uh at google but
going all the way back before uh gsb so
i went to undergrad um at mit and i was
actually in biological sciences um
definitely thought i was going to be a
doctor
at that point in time in my life and
then um ended up uh really
as many people do towards the end of my
college experience really not knowing
what i want to do my life so i end up in
consulting um but luckily uh the time of
the part of consulting i was in i was
doing innovation and r d consulting for
um big companies and really um at that
point uh realized that i loved kind of
the idea of
exploring something from scratch or
something novel or something um
unchartered and so i
had the realization i was like yes i
move to san francisco and start working
at startups so i ended up taking a job
at a startup and also applying to
business school at that point in time um
really focused on learning about
entrepreneurship and trying to fill that
gap and i was lucky enough to get into
the gsb
and really since then my career has
always been about startups so um ended
up working in venture capital for a
little bit at highland capital partners
doing some entrepreneurial things on my
own and then now i'm leading a lot of
our startup work here at google
and running a lot of our accelerator
programs and and some of our uh angel
investment funds and things like that so
um really fun work uh i also
hearing everyone
it brought me back as i uh so many of my
favorite memories were just uh the
one-on-one connections that i have with
so many of the individuals and those
chance chances to have those autistic
conversations and hear people speak so
passionately about their journeys and i
remember actually john i don't know if
you remember this but i remember
actually meeting you at our like first
first first
admit welcome event in boston and
learning about
the work that you're doing and and just
being so not
having these conversations with
individuals who are just so passionate
about so many different spaces and i
think when i think about my favorite gsb
moments that was are them right where
whether it's the large group scenarios
or the small group scenarios the talks
or the trips or even just the the casual
lunches with someone new in times square
it was just hearing people speak so
passionately about areas that i knew
nothing about whether it's media or
fashion or retail or robotics and so um
that was what was magical for me about
gsb and still is
the kind of diversity of perspective
expertise and kind of passion
awesome thank you so much for sharing um
i do want to just for educational
purposes for those on um like some
acronyms were mentioned that i want to
make sure everyone understands what they
are because there's a lot of acronyms at
the gsc um and so the gst was mentioned
this is called this stands for global
study trip and then gmix was mentioned
this is a global management immersion
experience um and these are two ways you
can fulfill another acronym which is
your ger which is your global experience
requirement so a big component of the
learning at the gsb is not just in
classroom which next question just to t
that up might be about a class that
impacted you guys since none of you
shared about academics but um which is
fine but um but also a big component is
hands-on experiential learning and
getting out of your comfort zone so that
idea of um you know embracing uh like
what jason said the diversity of
perspectives and that can be done in a
lot of different ways whether it's
conversations or travel and that is
something that is hugely embraced and
encouraged at the gsb uh that said so
our academics and so i'd love to um
just circle back with you guys about
um perhaps you know you're five years
out now um you all took the foundational
courses but you also because it's a
general management program took
electives um pretty soon on in your
first year and then all of your second
year um were there any classes that you
found to be like the most impactful
either during your time here and you
don't use it at all now or just you know
as you are five years out and you are
in your organizations and and working is
there anything you look back on that has
helped you so much from the gsb
uh let's start with
uh john this time
sure so uh there's a bunch of classes
that i would list up here
i think
probably the most impactful is one
called managing growing enterprises
which i think for a lot of folks i think
a lot of folks would agree that that was
a pretty impactful class
um this is one where
it's it's very case-based um but for me
for me the special part of the
case-based bit was that more often than
not the protagonists of the case would
join you in the class
and at least for the first class was a
bit of a surprise they don't tell you
that that's what's going to happen
but uh i think
in the course of going through the
uh the different challenges that each of
these you know entrepreneurs faced when
they were when they were building their
businesses um
you learn a lot about the way that they
thought about it versus the way that you
would think about it because the
the method within the course is
the instructors will often
effectively role play the scenarios out
and it teaches you a lot about
uh
about
effectively
good ways and ways that work in ways
that don't work for handling difficult
conversations and other kind of like
personnel and
sometimes strategic related uh things
that come up just on a day-to-day basis
and while the focus is a lot on
either startups or executive level stuff
it's uh
you end up with a with a perspective
that cuts across lots of lots of
different areas and you can apply it
even immediately after gsb it it doesn't
have any any relevance to
it doesn't strictly have relevance to
things five ten years out so
that was
for me that was the most impactful
course
great thanks for sharing um hurrah do
you mind sharing a course that impacted
you or that yeah yeah definitely before
before i share like to build and john's
for like the the managing growing
enterprise is definitely something you
could we carry for life but for me the
most memorable for that one was because
i like i don't play to fire someone as a
board member
and that someone who is a ceo chairman i
la i was working for him three years
later just imagine the situation you
fired the person in the class
to not be the ceo but he still is of
course and
i learned it or working this is kevin
terry really teaches at the gsb as well
um but for me like one of my most
favorite class like there were
definitely several but um it was a class
i took at the last quarter was called
art of self coaching it was with coach
colette batista i think he teaches a lot
of different things but it was like it
helped me sum up my gsb experience a lot
and how to
carry that forward and continue to have
the learning even after gsb so um he
went a lot into just happiness and
reflection and thinking about it which
truly summarized and i still follow his
blog a lot and from time to time ask him
a lot of situational questions
um he's he's a coach to a lot of
executives at like startups and tech
companies um but for me like that was
like the most reflective class that
helped me kind of put my entire
experience together so highly encourage
when people get in to take that one
thank you
emily do you mind sharing yours
sure well someone has to do it and i'll
do it my
really
impactful class was interpersonal
dynamics
um touchy-feely
i think i think it's called
interpersonal dynamics right it is
what i remember it as um
and honestly like all classes like that
like those are the classes that i really
appreciated um so like um
high performance leadership
things like coaching all my fellows
classes
i think because like so much of why i
came to business school was to
like work on my own confidence and work
on my like
belief that i belonged in the business
world and so much of what those classes
accomplished for me
was like a real
space and time to like deeply understand
myself and that's such a
rare thing and such a kind of like
selfish thing in some ways
to be able to spend two years
understanding that stuff
um
and you know i i think now as a result
of those classes i'm a
i don't remember a lot of the like
really specifics of the finance classes
i took or anything like that um i'm sure
there's gonna be another great example
from other people of that um
but for me like those classes are why
i'm like the leader i am now today and
the organizations i'm in because i know
who i am because
i
know what i want other people to feel
like when i interact with them i'm
like
not i'm like cool with the things that
make me emotional and i'm cool with the
things that make me
um me
uh
and all that stuff is like very very
hard i think to
to like to learn or to give yourself
space to do and so
um i will forever forever be grateful
for
for the time to do that and how stanford
enabled that
awesome thanks for sharing and jason is
there anything else to add about a class
that impacted you
um mine is um
somewhat polarizing for both current
students and former students but and
even for myself but the class that i say
to this day that i remember and think
about the most was this class called
path to power it talks about power and
influence and understanding your power
and influence within scenarios and and i
think ultimately where i came out is is
how to make sure you use your power and
influence for good and and are conscious
about that and so for me i sit in
meetings all day every day where i'm
thinking about influence and and what
are the power dynamics in those rooms
and and how do you make sure that you're
conscious of them and intentional about
your behavior and and how it might
influence decisions and and how people
feel i guess and so um and using power
for good uh so and not not having power
be a bad word i guess is also something
that i think a lot of us took away from
that class awesome thank you for sharing
yeah i feel like um
the examples you guys all gave
especially the art of self-coaching and
interpersonal dynamics and paths to
power are also a highlight another thing
that's really important to the gsb
experience which is the idea of
developing yourself as a leader um at
the gsb um you know you can
uh get schooled in finance and strategy
and things like that in a lot of
different places but really um
developing yourself as a leader to go
out and and manage people and
organizations is a key component of the
program here um i'm gonna ask one more
question and then i'll start kind of
taking them from the audience so i thank
everyone for for posting their questions
i'm seeing them and this actually
relates to one of the ones that's been
upvoted but you guys are all five years
out
um and you came into the gsb with an
idea perhaps of what it is you wanted to
do maybe or at least maybe what you
wanted to get out of um an mba program
and so just seeing where you are now and
this is somewhat of a deep question but
are you where you thought you'd be
um and for those who maybe are that's
awesome we'd love to hear that and for
those who have pivoted or changed
um we want to hear that too and i'd also
um
kind of infused in that answer if if it
has impacted you but like how what role
has the stanford network played in
helping you um in your five years
post gsb
so
we'll go backwards now we'll start with
jason
you gave me the literally i was like
please don't sorry for this question
but no no no it works um
i mean
no i think in short because i don't
think i knew where i would be and i
don't think i i think um as you do in
many situations you get around all these
amazing people and you go through the
the journey of of
am i doing do i belong here am i did i
am i supposed to be here and then you
get the confidence back and such so i
think um the idea of where where i would
be in five years changed so much
throughout the gsb but i think
ultimately i'm still
chasing my north star which is what is
what was most important and i think
really when i look back to the answer
and the question of what matters most
and why i think i'm still
headed into that direction even though
what i do functionally on a day-to-day
basis is not i had no idea that this is
what i would be doing i think back then
um but to the power i think your last
point is what was super
important for me i think
i think i even underestimated the power
of the gsb network um i to this day even
within my not just people within my
class but
even when at work and i like find out
someone was a gsb alum and then all of a
sudden we're like
best buddies and then we're like
collaborating and things like that and
it's just the network is so powerful and
it truly has created such tangible value
um in my in my life and my career and
and and i wouldn't be where i am today
without it so um for
i mean maybe hopefully i would have made
it somewhat eventually but i definitely
wouldn't have gotten here as fast it was
definitely a challenge than that and so
um highly appreciative of it
awesome thank you um emily why don't we
go next to you
okay
um i also want to say that i didn't say
this at the beginning but also one of my
key memories is always dancing on the
dance floor with jason scott he is one
of the best dancers in the world and
every wedding i've been to with him is
the more fun because of him every party
at the gsb is more fun because of him
the like
like the square was more fun because of
him so anyway
i need to afford that answer yeah yeah
um
uh cool um he's he can do it all he's a
renaissance man um
i think i
no i mean yes i had no idea where i
would be in five years i had ideas and
thoughts that like i was very passionate
about retail and i was passionate about
consumer
and i wanted to go to stanford to
connect consumer to
um like the future of innovation and
retail um so that in some ways i think
has played out which is interesting
although i would have never expected to
be at a home interiors company and
slinging wallpaper
but um
i i do think that
what i would say is that stamp stamp
like the stanford alumni network has
been like instrumental to
every career choice i've made opposed to
the gsb like i at every moment where i
was thinking about leaving or staying
somewhere
like the first people i called were my
gsb colleagues whether it was like emily
or sarah or sarah i think i want to go
into a startup but i don't know which
one like your vc tell me the ones that
are good and tell me the ones that i
should stay away from or
um
i don't know just even sharing any of my
life moments now like gs beers are the
people that i want to do that with like
there are two gs beers in my living room
right now like
drinking tequila and eating cheese while
i'm on this call so um
the network is like are my like sort of
cornerstones like the touch points that
help me to decide what's next and to
help me like reground myself and who i
am
and i think like to jason's point
i still think i'm like for sure on the
journey of like
what do i want to be when i grow up who
am i
um
but i feel very very fortunate that i
have all these humans in my corner that
are both experts in their fields or
um who just know me so well that they
can say like emily no you don't want to
do that that doesn't sound like anything
you would ever want to do um
so
yes yeah no to no to being where i am
where i thought i would be five years
from the uh gsb but yes to
stanford being exceptionally like
instrumental in in my current life
awesome thank you um why don't you
answer that nut
yeah so i think for me i didn't know
like i want to always stay in technology
but not exactly know what function or
job i would be doing so like i think
when you ask this question i think most
of us entered gsb writing an essay but
definitely still figuring things out i
was i i still joke that i think one of
the reasons i went to business school
was because i didn't know what to do
with life
and
uh thankfully it it helped me at least
discover what i don't want um so i did i
i chose more of a path of elimination to
figure things out uh uh
um but one of the i think where just
really helped and uh you know is like i
think accelerated a little bit of how
what i would have thought about
especially when it came to managing
people and giving me the confidence to
raise my hand and to ask for what i want
whereas prior to that you know i think
going back to emily's point like
confidence is definitely one of the
things gsb helped us with it definitely
broke us down in the first quarter but
then helped us build it
uh
uh like i mean just having been in
engineering and all i was definitely
very much like an ic contributing things
but quickly right after like six or nine
eight months after gsb i'm like hiring
people i'm like going back and hiring
from the gsb hiring from elsewhere and i
didn't i wouldn't have had the
confidence to do that or even put my
name in the head like last year
switching to corporate strategy doing
more strategy working for chairman ceo
directly um so i think that's probably
where i see like where the five years
out has helped me and i still see a lot
of my friends who've done masters in
csnl um
you know where i stand is quite
different and a lot of that i attribute
to the gsb the network for sure but also
just the confidence it built in to go
ask for things
awesome thanks and john do you want to
chime in there
sure yeah so i think i i
i had a couple of short-term goals going
into the gsb um
which i think generally is fairly
tactical in trying to execute on those
which is to make the conversion into
from being an individual contributor
engineer into being in product
and starting to think about things in
less of a kind of narrow technologically
focused way
but broadly i think
you know everything everything that the
other panelists of my classmates have
said resonates which is it's very hard
to put a five-year plan out there i i
did certainly didn't do that
because it's just be
just just kept some general goals um
and i think
i don't know i think things have have
worked out in a way that i'm really
happy with but i can't say that i
planned it um
and in terms of uh gsb alum involvement
i mean the first job i got out of gsp
through irobot i
was introduced to it by reaching out to
a gsb alum who worked there and had a
conversation and the funny thing is this
actually i applied for the job
originally without without knowing
anybody and
was rejected almost right off of that
and then i reached out to an alum who
was at the company and immediately got a
conversation with the hiring manager so
it's funny how that works um
and then
and then the uh the second job that i
had out of gsb after after i robot i had
been to the company for a couple of
years i kind of learned the ropes of
what it takes to launch a consumer
product um and had gotten a couple
launches under my belt was like okay
i really wanna get into the startup
world um i want to instead of taking an
existing product from
um you know
to improve its profitability and reach i
want to go from zero to one i want to
help bring
new robotics technologies automation
technologies into the world in a way
that's actually meaningful and can
provide value um who's doing that so
there's as in the boston area and
there's a bunch of robotics companies in
the boston area and i knew a few
folks at them from
uh from
from other
periods in my life but
i actually found that uh there was a gsb
alum on the board of berkshire gray and
i just reached out to him and he
immediately got me a conversation with
the ceo
so like those those sorts of tactical
things are that's
that's how the gsb alumni network can
be extremely helpful uh in that regard
um but you know at a more personal level
uh i rely on my gsb friends for advice
all the time um similar to similar to
what emily mentioned um it's a really
great support system um folks who
actually
you know they might not be in your
direct industry but there's lots of
corollaries they might invest in your
industry they might have consulted for
companies in your industry like there's
there's just so many different angles of
attack that you have uh with your
friends and colleagues and
through the gsb network that you get to
you get to develop a really strong
perspective on a space before you even
enter it um and that's a huge advantage
awesome thank you for sharing i'm john
while i have you there was a question
specific to gmix and since you had
shared that you did a gmix i'd love to
to direct that towards you um
when doing a gmix um first just how easy
was it to do um and if you could talk a
little bit about the support you
received from the program office in
terms of the ger the team that kind of
oversees global experiences um but also
uh are you able to customize your
experience you know is there a way you
know how do you kind of get placed into
a company and things like that if you
could talk a little bit more about that
that'd be great sure um so in terms of
the customization aspect that's not a
route that i took though i'm i'm not
sure if it's possible i imagine that it
is i think that there are folks who have
sourced their own gmix opportunities um
but what i did is i think what the
majority of people do be
career office sources a bunch of
opportunities from companies who are
looking to bring gsbeers in
um and they'll open up a couple of spots
and there's a huge list and i
i would be surprised if all of them get
stabbed because there seems to be more
demand for uh for gsb talent
than can be fully supplied um
but uh yeah so i i identified a couple
of opportunities and um really what you
do is at least in my experiences i
chatted with a bunch of the
people who had created those
opportunities in those companies and
you basically try to find out what's a
good fit for what they're looking for
and what you're looking for so um
it's
it's partially curated and that there's
a certain amount of value that the
companies are looking for like they want
you to do something for them um it's
it's not just you know you go have a fun
time like you actually have to
contribute something
and that's even more rewarding because
of it
so i remember i was talking to
uh
some folks in germany i forget what they
were doing at this point um buenos aires
and there was another one too
that i spoke with but uh
yeah i really clicked with the with the
argentine team um and because they were
offering something that was very product
focused and at that point i hadn't
really done anything in product
management my previous internship so i
did two internships that summer i did
one in business development at sri uh
earlier in the summer which was not
product related that was much more in my
research wheelhouse from previously and
then the product one
in argentina really um
really struck a chord and i was what
they were looking for and
they were what i was looking for so that
that's that's how it worked out um i
don't know if there's an aspect of the
question that i've missed but i think i
will say no that's great and i think um
because you didn't customize yours
that's absolutely fine but just to
answer the question there it is possible
to customize your experience actually i
believe in if you guys do head nods but
i believe that you can customize not
just gmix but let's say a global study
trip is uh there isn't a global study
trip offered that really is kind of
an area or a place you want to focus on
or go to which is hard to imagine
because there's such a plethora of
choices each year but um you can also
design and that's really what the global
experiences team is there for they're
part of the mba programs office and
they're there to help
you make sure that you're able to
fulfill that requirement in a way that
works for you so there are lots of
different ways to do that um one of the
other questions out there i'm going to
direct this to each of you to share you
can share a little bit or a lot um in
terms of this but you know for you when
you were at the gsp what did a typical
day look like and you don't have to walk
through a whole day but i think really
the question is getting at how do you
balance um
studying and clubs and recruiting um and
you know maybe what some people i i
always tell you from the admissions
perspective and having interacted with
students over the years it's like i
think a lot of times you have to choose
and prioritize because time is
definitely the biggest commodity so
maybe if you could share
um of an extracurricular activity you
were involved in like just in that way
and as an example of perhaps um
highlighting you know maybe how you
spent your time and this is you know
largely outside of academics then what
were you involved in um
why don't we start with you
yeah um i was thinking it's like
doing really taking us back to that time
right um before i share the answer i
think our class started this week in a
life off so if i think it might still be
online so i would encourage people to
read that
um and it really talks through a
day-to-day breakdown of
what uh someone is going through um i
think for me like yeah typical day like
going back to prioritization as a
product person that's something i'm
constantly thinking about so that's how
like even at the gsb you approach uh but
we used to have that joke right you have
your study social and sleep the three
things and you can choose two out of
those three at a given point in time
um but for me i think going in having a
little bit clearer picture for me like
socializing meeting the people all of
that it was important and it was
actually challenging myself because i
had always been so academic
so study focused and only worried about
that growing up in an environment like
that was to actually not
worry about the grades so like not not
to say you should not get good grades
but
not like it's more about what you're
learning out of it versus just ticking a
box which is what i was trained to be in
the past so going to the question of
like you know just how we managed the
different times i think
i know gsp is also very good with like
giving us the focus time when it is a
recruiting season and stuff or like also
delaying people to come on campus
company so you get the time to adjust
um but discovering through the social
piece is like important i think and how
uh we go about the day-to-day life so
yeah definitely it's like getting your
goals for like the weekly or quarterly
and then focusing on what you want to
get out has been more important to me
some things emily could you share
sure i'll try i'll do second year
because second year i really had lots of
fun and i figured out like to harrell's
point i figured out my priorities a
little bit better first year i was sort
of like a chicken with my head cut off
i didn't really know what i wanted and
there was so much to do and i wanted to
do everything um but second year i got
very into being healthy so i'd wake up
really early and exercise i went to like
ridiculous
palo alto exercise classes um and then
there's probably like let's say on any
given day i had like two classes um so i
gonna be totally honest i'd like
you know uh cram in the case right
before the class and make sure that i
had like some working knowledge of what
was happening when i walked in um and
honestly like the discussions and
conversations were amazing but um so
there was like some portion of my day
that was that a lot of portion of my day
that was socializing in the like main
quad area which i don't even what was
the name old town square old square what
was it what i don't remember the name so
no someone needs to help me out town
square oh it's town square okay no i was
combining town square with old town road
i think that song um so spending a lot
of time there eating lunch packing in my
like salad as much there was like an
amazing like salad deal
um
and then i probably have like two or
three club meetings i was really
involved in women in management so i
would do that for a little bit
um i
was involved in the retail club so i
would do that um and then i would like
hang out with my roommates and we would
like plan for we'd be hosted a lot of
like small group dinners at our uh house
um which meant like stanford gave us
money to like
bring people over to our house and have
dinner
um and then you know occasionally we
were like maybe we should also do this
with professors so we brought professors
and um had them come over to our house
for dinner
uh and then jason was reminding me there
was like some fun parties that we went
to um or you know just different
activities and leagues and stuff so we
went to and then i would probably do
that and then i would repeat the next
day um and it was amazing and so much
fun
uh so that was day in the life i think
awesome thank you
um jason
since she mentioned you
yeah i won't share a day in life because
that was a horrible example of
prioritization and so my learning goal
you set learning goals with your uh
groups
in week one and my learning goal that
was forced upon me was to learn to say
no um because i was i've always been a
yes person and so um
i can talk about pretty much every extra
curricular because i was probably
involved um and i definitely out of the
not just involved you could lead it like
literally lead it yeah
and out of the three choices that harald
mentioned i think i gave up sleep so i
definitely pulled way more all-nighters
that i would ever recommend just to like
plan
the gsb show or plan a study trip or
plan something for folks um because i
love i just love the community so much
so what i will say is there's something
for everyone whether you want a club
around bc or a club around uh people who
love media and the arts or if you want
to club around robotics or or honestly
if you want to spend time at other
schools law school the med school
there's so many choices so what i would
advise is thinking of your framework
early of what
our priorities for you um which i tell
startups all the time think of your okrs
and don't do anything else but think of
your priorities and what um um you want
to say yes to and truly learn to say no
to 80 of things because
um
they're just so many options and it's
really tough to to prioritize and you
don't want to spread yourself to them
awesome thanks and john do you want to
chime in there
yeah sure i mean
big plus one
yeah
ruthless prioritization
and figuring out what your goals are
because there's there's way too much
going on to be able to do all of it um
yeah i mean for me you know yes
class is usually going on in the
mornings but i had a couple of classes
that would go on in the evenings uh and
in the in between time um
i
spent a bunch of time in the practice
design manufacturing club as you might
expect um
and
a lot of one-on-ones with folks uh
especially people who
were
like in related industries especially
second year i spent a bunch of time
trying to learn as much about different
companies as i could so that could be
having coffee chat with your professor
who's a vc and invests in a couple of
these types of companies or
maybe driving up to sf and going and
seeing someone shop and what they're
doing um or going over to sandhill road
and
being shown around by
so the portfolio of companies by one of
the investors there like there's just um
there's a lot of that uh especially
second year because for me second year
was all about trying to figure out
exactly what i'm gonna do
when i leave the place
but also there's a ton of socializing i
would play tennis with uh with folks
often
multiple times a week
and um and sometimes volunteer a little
bit too
there's a program called east palo alto
tennis tutoring which
i would help out with uh there's
basically kids would get tutored and
then they would go out and hit the
tennis ball around with some folks who
um who volunteered to do so
uh and that was that was kind for me
that was like a little bit of a
grounding experience because um you know
being being within the gsb there's a lot
going on and it feels like its own world
in some respects but it's also good to
get to get out of it a little bit um and
then uh
i loved living in my past down house um
my housemates and i spent a lot of time
together uh whether it was
you know having cookouts or you know
playing random board games and having
folks over it was uh
uh that social experience was
was
probably one of the one of the most
tight-knit social experiences that i
that i had at gsb um
and those are probably the people that i
most rely on for
for advice these days um but yeah
there's no shortage of things to do
awesome thanks for sharing and just for
those on the call pass downhouse is a
term
that is used within the gsb community
because many first-year gsb students
will live on campus and when i say many
it's it's in the high 90 percent um
they'll either live in
buildings that are directly across the
street from the gsb or other housing
available on the stanford campus but
after that in second year it is common
to move um to
the area around the campus and in what
they call passed down houses houses that
over the years have always been rented
to gsb students and just continue to be
passed down so that's um that term uh
jason earlier you had mentioned that you
actually do refer back to your what
matters most a question that you
answered in in your application and you
know we're speaking today to a bunch of
people on this call who are embarking on
that application process i'm just
curious from the others um how often you
might also think about your what matters
most question and whether you kind of
use that as an anchor point ever in in
your life today
um maybe emily i see you smiling so i
don't know if that's a yes or no
i'm smiling because i know someone who's
on that who's an attendee on this panel
who i've been talking about my what
matters most okay um essay with a lot
with um
so honestly i hadn't looked at it in a
really long time um and when i went back
to it
i
was one reminded exactly what i said
which was good um and like you could
keep myself honest about like okay well
how are you living your values
um and i think like what i'm really
proud of is that like sure it didn't
look like the exact career path that i
thought was going to connect to that
maybe i haven't achieved that yet but
the
like the work i did then to like think
about what mattered to me and um like it
still like threads through all that i do
at work all that i do in my like
personal life
um so without like going super into all
of you um
like 100 it's like
it's something that i'm quite proud of
is that
i live a life and i work um in my career
in a way that like reflects my values um
and so yeah but i hadn't thought about
it in a really long time and as i was um
going through this like application
process with this friend
um
i was just reminded that it was a really
sort of
exhausting vulner it felt like
exhausting and vulnerable to go through
the application process um
because i really took it seriously and i
really wanted to think about what
mattered to me
um and so i just want for everybody
who's applying right now
like
it's gonna be okay
like you are going to like it's like
such a gift to be able to like think
about these questions um and even though
it's also so annoying i'm sure and
frustrating and you wish you didn't have
to do it or all the things
um
like the application process really i
think is a really good reflection of
what stanford wants out of like its
community members and is a really good
like way for you to like also test like
do i want what stanford wants right
um so
application process is okay i promise
you'll get through it and then the other
side is like a really beautiful thing
i was gonna say plus one on the on that
essay is like yeah i've told mine like
couple times i think the best advice i
got is like write it as if you're really
telling that to yourself no one else is
watching
and that's kind of when you really
hit that um to kind of just answer that
question for me like what like
definitely what matter most is something
that is i care a lot about is um around
community and povertying others
especially women and they're coming from
a culture
um that i had to fight my way through it
like it's something that is near and
dear that i've always been part of like
i launched the women in tech at apple
um continued to stay involved at gsb in
the women in business and like even
right now being sponsors to those but
and uh going to the women's circle
program alyssa you mentioned like i just
joined the global management board for
it to evangelize that across different
regions to grow that so
um it's definitely a part of who i am it
doesn't have to always be just the
professional career you choose
um or like you know just life it's just
like how you operate what are your
values what are some things that you
deeply care about that will go with you
no matter and it's definitely something
that has stayed true
uh throughout the journey
awesome thanks for sharing um john
anything to add to that
um
not a whole lot i mean in terms of the
what matters most to you and why um
for me i haven't referred back to the
actual text that i put in the
application i think since i wrote it um
but the general the
the general framework uh
that i wrote about it remains my
personal guiding framework um so uh
in that sense yes i'm always referring
back to like hey
why do i want to make this decision um
and being very deliberate about it like
i think that that's that's really where
it manifests itself most often is
a when you're faced with a difficult
decision
how do you weigh your options uh and b
how do you how do you treat and interact
with people on a daily basis um and i
think gsb's
general philosophy uh focuses on making
sure that when you do those things you
do them with uh with intention and
authenticity
and
to me that's that's one of my biggest
the biggest gains that i got from gsp
experience
awesome thank you so much i do want to
do a quick like rapid response because
we only have about two more minutes so
if there is anything you wish you could
have done differently because again this
is a five years out so just thinking a
lot back to your time
is there anything you would have done
differently yes or no and then if so
what and it can be a really short answer
because we are stripped for time but i'd
love to do just like a rapid response on
that um
jason do you wanna
die
i feel like i get all the hard questions
first but no i think i spoke to it
earlier um
i think going into first year i think
second year i really um did a good job
of kind of thinking about
how to say no what my priorities are and
kind of what that framework is and also
also not feeling as rushed and thinking
of life is a series of incremental steps
versus hopping straight to that perfect
spot and so i think first year if i
could have adopted that mentality
earlier i might have had a lot more
peace
and not felt not felt as scrambling yeah
john how about you
interestingly i might
i might i'm going to go the opposite of
jason just because my personality is to
i usually find my comfort zone and kind
of kind of stay there
and i think at gsb i push myself to be a
little bit more
exploratory and
try and you know try new things compared
to what i would do otherwise but
i still think i could have i could have
gotten even more out of the experience
if i had let my uh
let my exploration side of things go a
little bit more um if i'd spent a little
bit more time socializing maybe a little
bit less time
reading like reading
the cases um yeah so that's what
happened
thanks for sharing um emily really
quickly
wouldn't change i think it was pretty
good but if i had to choose i would say
jason's but i i'd like actually the
exact same thing that jason said except
i think that was part of the journey and
that's why i like got to second year and
was able to do second year the way i did
and i don't know i
believe me i
screwed up and messed things up and
things were hard sometimes but
i think it was all part of the journey
yeah awesome and her all will give you a
chance i was going to say like more
travel
if that counts
but more travel more to build the
relationships with others right so more
one-on-ones more small group dinners and
more travel is going to be fun
thank you so much to all four of you for
being on we are so appreciative and
there's a quick poll just to get some
feedback on the event that we'd love for
everyone who's on to fill out i saw so
many questions we didn't get to um some
we touched on but others around
you know having master's degrees before
coming and different questions i would
encourage you to check out our class
profile online and other resources we
have on the gsb
website um just so you can find out more
information and we encourage you to
check our events webpage to come to
future events and to continue um you
know learning more and helping having us
support you on your journey again thank
you to our panelists you guys were
awesome mini class of 16 reunion and um
i appreciate your time and thank you to
everyone who attended again good morning
good evening good afternoon wherever you
are
thank you so much for your time today
everyone
[Music]